Apple has recently submitted some
filings to the EEC and one of them is
for a portable personal computer running
Mac OS 10.15 and based on past
experience this could only mean one
thing a MacBook and it means that a new
one is coming soon but which MacBook we
don't know but we do have a couple of
ideas so in this video we're gonna talk
about the MacBook model we think it's
most likely to be and why as well as a
runner-up possibility that isn't as
likely but would definitely be an
awesome addition to the Apple MacBook
lineup with the success of the 16 inch
MacBook Pro including the new magic
keyboard which most people including us
absolutely love it would make sense for
Apple to switch the rest of their
MacBook lineup over to using that magic
keyboard the whole butterfly keyboard
debacle was horrible for Apple they went
through multiple class-action lawsuits
in an expensive free repair program for
Mac books with butterfly keyboards not
only that but the general consensus was
that all Mac books with butterfly
keyboards are flawed and a lot of people
chose to go with Windows laptops because
of it
the only solution was to create a new
keyboard the magic keyboard and people
are loving it and a lot of people who
are wanting a smaller MacBook are
sitting and waiting for a refresh with
the new keyboard so with that we
personally believe that this mystery
MacBook is either an update to the
13-inch MacBook Pro to include the magic
keyboard or a full redesign that will
bring the display size up to 14 inches
and include a bunch of other feature
changes either way were most likely to
see a switch to Intel's 10 nanometer
processors which should give us a small
boost in processing performance but a
pretty huge boost and graphics
performance with the new iris pro
graphics this is going to be the biggest
deal for the smaller macbook pro since
graphics is the biggest bottleneck on
this machine as for processing we don't
expect it to change much other than the
chance that we'll actually be able to
upgrade to a 6 core processor on the
high end 13 or possibly 14-inch model
now this would give us a big boost and
processing power as well we can also
expect upgrades to battery life possibly
a thicker
body with better cooling better speakers
microphones and more just like we saw on
the 16 inch macbook pro however don't
get too excited
we here at Mac's sec are pretty sure
that only the higher-end
$1,800 model is gonna be updated or
refreshed with these new features or at
least at first now why would we think so
well because it's happened before in
2018 Apple updated the 13-inch MacBook
Pro with the touch bar a quad core
processor and other features but the
lower-end $1300 model stayed exactly the
same for another year
this gave people a lot of incentive to
spend a few hundred dollars more for a
newer and more capable MacBook but if
Apple would have updated both of them at
the same time not a lot of people would
want to spend the extra cash on the
higher-end
$1,800.00 model for a little bit more
performance and features and that's why
we think Apple will do the same thing
again this year the only difference is
that the current $1300 MacBook Pro is an
excellent deal it's actually the best
bang for the buck model in terms of
processor performance per dollar out of
any mac book including the 16 inch
macbook pro and that's because it was
updated last year with a quad core
processor which is enough for most
people making it an excellent value even
now in 2020 especially when it's on sale
for $100 off like it is right now on
Amazon which will link to down below so
because it's still a great value it
doesn't really make sense for Apple to
update the lower end model at the same
time as the $1,800 model this means that
for those who aren't planning on
spending $1,800 on the upcoming 13 or 14
inch macbook pro replacement it actually
makes more sense to just buy the lower
end model right now and enjoy it for the
next few months instead of waiting but
for those who have the cash ready the
upcoming MacBook Pro refresh is going to
be great especially if it's refreshed
with a new 14 inch display now let's
talk about the other possibility that
this mystery macbook might become
there's a chance that it could actually
be the return of the 12 inch MacBook
with one very important change the
switch to Apple's arm-based processors
basically a processor that's similar to
what comes in an iPhone or an iPad Apple
discontinued the 12-inch MacBook last
year because it didn't really have a
strong place in the MacBook lineup but
if Apple were to switch to ARM
processors the 12-inch MacBook would
actually make the most sense
Microsoft has recently tried this with
their surface pro X which packs an ARM
processor however their product has a
high price and is aimed at the pro
market so people have high expectations
for it
and unfortunately the software is
running a little bit behind not being
able to support all the negative 64-bit
apps that many people expect to use on a
pro device like Photoshop and other apps
it actually has to use an emulator to
run 64-bit apps causing them to run very
slowly compared to what people are used
to and even then not all apps work so a
lot of customers and reviewers were not
happy with the surface pro X this is
actually the same thing Apple wants to
do they you want to switch their Mac's
from Intel chips over to their own ARM
chips and even Intel is expecting Apple
to switch to arm chips this year in 2020
and this isn't something new last year
at WWDC Apple announced their catalyst
project and it has one main goal
creating a new and simple way to turn
iPad apps into fully native Mac apps
they're basically creating the software
that could end up being used to not only
make iOS apps run on Mac OS but also do
the reverse half Mac apps run on ARM
processors but of course this transition
is going to be rough and that's why it
makes the most sense for the very first
ARM based MacBook to be a very low-end
and cheap MacBook that doesn't really
have high expectations for performance
but it could make for a super portable
machine with amazing battery life and if
Apple priced their first arm packing
MacBook at around $1000 the bulk of the
market will be using it for common tasks
like web browsing
streaming video and using simple apps no
one will be expecting it to have the
fastest performance for a bunch of
high-end apps so there'll be less issues
with it and it will allow Apple to start
working on the software and getting it
ready for the rest of their higher-end
MacBook lineup now I know it's much more
likely that this mystery
book is a refresh 13 or 14 inch MacBook
Pro but Apple is going to be switching
to ARM processors soon so there's always
that small chance that it'll happen but
whatever ends up being will be right
here making videos on it so if you're
not already subscribed go ahead and
click the circle above to do so right
now and check out one of those two
videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]